[موسيقى] أصبح
التلوث البلاستيكي من الزجاجات إلى الأكياس
والتعبئة وصمة عار على مناظرنا الطبيعية ، حيث
يتم إنتاج 350 مليون طن من البلاستيك سنويًا ، ينتهي بعضها
كقمامة في محيطاتنا في
شوارعنا وعبر صحارينا ولكن مثل القديمة  يقول
يقول إن قمامة رجل ما هي كنز رجل آخر
مدفوعًا بشغف للقضاء على التلوث البلاستيكي
، لقد أخذ كريستيان وإيما الحلاق
إعادة التدوير وأضفته إلى فكرتهما الكبيرة
، قميصي مصنوع من زجاجات بلاستيكية معاد تدويرها
لا أكرهني لأنني  البلاستيك
والقميص الخاص بك مصنوع من البحث
، الفكرة الكبيرة هي تحويل
الزجاجات البلاستيكية إلى منسوجات ،
كان علينا أن نصل إلى
المستوى الأساسي ونشارك
في الواقع جميع موظفينا
في حملات تنظيف تحاول تعظيم
معدلات
الاسترداد لأن معدلات الاسترداد خاصة في هذه المنطقة
هي واحدة من أدنى المعدلات في العالم ،
ما يجعل شركة إعادة تدوير البلاستيك الخاصة بهم
أكثر ابتكارًا
هو أنهم قلقون  k مباشرة مع
الشركات
[الموسيقى]
مثل شركة المياه هذه والأحداث الكبيرة
مثل الصيغة الأولى في أبو ظبي التي
تجمع البلاستيك وإعادة تدويره عن طريق
إنتاج
النسيج وبيعه مرة أخرى إلى الشركات
كزي موحد للموظفين
مثل بنطلونات التويل أو حتى قمصان البوب ، هذ
هو  تمامًا مثل
البوليستر التقليدي ، وقد صنعنا هذا
الزي الرسمي في الواقع للصيغة التي قام بها
فريق واحد بعد أن جمعوا البلاستيك
من حدث العام الماضي من
خلال جهود إعادة التدوير التي بذلوها ،
فقد صنعوا ما يصل إلى 200 نوع مختلف من
الأقمشة
ووضعوا علامة تجارية على خيوطهم تسمى greenspun
[موسيقى
] وهم يزعمون أن عمليات التصنيع الخاصة بهم
أكثر
صداقة للبيئة
من عمليات إنتاج المنسوجات التقليدية ،
ما نقوم به هو تعطيل تمامًا
للتصنيع الشائع للبوليستر ، فنحن نستخدم
كمية أقل من الكهرباء و 20 كمية أقل من
المياه وننتج 55 انبعاثات كربون أقل
من إنتاج البوليستر من نقطة
الصفر  كل جزء من رؤيتهم
للانتقال نحو ما هو k  يُعرف
باسم الاقتصاد الدائري للبلاستيك
حيث لا يصبح فيه أي نفايات أو
تلوث
ويتم إعادة استخدامه باستمرار ،
إنه عكس
الاقتصاد الخطي التقليدي حيث يتم تصنيع الأشياء
ثم التخلص منها ، إنه مثال رائع
على كيفية عمل الاقتصاد الدائري
الذي لا يمكننا الاحتفاظ به  المضي قدمًا في
الاقتصاد الخطي ، لا يمكن للكوكب أن يحافظ عليه ،
وسوف تنفد الموارد
علينا أن نبدأ في تحويل الاقتصاد
الدائري حتى نعيد استخدام الموارد
ونعيد استخدام المنتجات
[الموسيقى]
مع الرؤية الواضحة لشركتهم
التي حددوها  مواقعهم خارج دبي ،
فإن الخطوات التالية بالنسبة لنا هي حقًا
توسيع نطاق الأعمال التجارية ، حيث سنرى
Greenpun كعلامة تجارية يمكن نشرها في
جميع أنحاء دول العالم الثالث
بالإضافة إلى أن تصبح علامة تجارية جادة
لتجار التجزئة
[موسيقى]